18:04 and the Ottoman Empire looks like
this Europe was in the mists of the
French Revolutionary Wars which had seen
an invasion of Egypt in 1798 alongside
the British the Ottomans pushed the
French out and during the chaos a man
caught Muhammad Ali an officer from the
albanian provinces seized control of
Egypt in 1805 becoming its Viceroy the
early 19th century also saw a revolt in
Serbia which began in 1804 in response
to their treatment by the ottomans the
Serbians asked Russia for help which the
Russians gave during the Russo Oxman war
which began in 1806 so the man in charge
of the Ottoman Empire at this point was
Sultan Selim the third who was primarily
a reformer and a moderniser one of these
reforms was the modernization of the
army this was resisted by the
Janissaries in order of what was
originally elite slave soldiers but over
time had become a corrupt bloated group
of politically active freemen Selim
created a new core of infantrymen called
the new order which doesn't sound
menacing at all the Janissaries revolted
to pose Selim in 1807 and replaced him
of the new Sultan Mustafa the fourth
Mustafa immediately faced a counter
rebellion and so he ordered that Selim
be killed as well as any other potential
heirs to secure his position he didn't
quite get them all though and so the
rebel army deposed him in favor of his
brother who became sold to man-bird ii
in 1808 in 1812 the ottomans signed a
peace treaty with the Russians yielding
this territory so the Serbian Revolution
was still ongoing at this point and
after a brief Ottoman reconquest Serbia
was granted the status of a semi
independent principality in 1817 this
would not be the last Ottoman defeat in
the Balkans though as demonstrated by
the Greek war of independence which
began in 1821 the Ottomans failed to
suppress the revolution and so mama
turned to Muhammad Ali of Egypt to help
which he did Ali was much more
successful than Mamet had been and
within three years the revolt was
essentially broken the Greek war of
independence had caught the eye of the
major powers though and Russia Britain
and France had been trying to pressure
the ottomans into letting Greece go
which they refused domestically Mamet
was attempting to modernize the Ottoman
state and like his predecessor he ran
into opposition from the Janissaries the
Janissaries revolted but unlike the last
time the Sultan's forces won and after
crushing them in 1826 Mahmud had the
Janissaries dissolved Mahmud oversaw
further reforms including granting
greater rights to the Christian and
Jewish minorities strengthening the
state by clamping down on tribal
allegiances and also relaxing clothing
laws which broke down social barriers in
1827 a naval standoff off the coast of
Greece here between the Great Powers and
the Ottomans
hot and the Ottoman Navy was crushed
French forces then landed in Greece and
the Egyptians soon after left in 1830
the great powers recognized Greece as an
independent republic and later a kingdom
also France to cow G Rhea the weakness
shown by the central Ottoman state was
capitalized upon by Muhammad Ali in 1831
Egypt which Muhammad Ali had grown to
this invaded and swept across the Levant
and into Anatolia by 1832 the Egyptian
territory looked like this and it looked
like the Egyptians were just about to
depose the Sultan but in a strange twist
of events the Russians intervened and
blocked the route to Constantinople
Britain and France put pressure on our
lien so in 1833 a peace treaty was
concluded which gave Egypt control of
this territory but it was still
technically a vassal of the Ottomans
tensions between Muhammad Ali and the
Ottoman Sultan remained throughout the
1830s and he's culminated in a second
war beginning in 1839 shortly after its
outbreak mammoth ii died and was
succeeded by his son abdul majeed the
war went pretty poorly for the ottomans
at first even though they started in it
was only through the intervention of
Russia Prussia Britain and the Austrian
Empire that Muhammad Ali agreed to peace
in 1841 this peace gave this territory
back to the Ottomans and saw Ali's
family recognized as the legitimate
rulers of Egypt
the reason the European powers were
desperate to intervene was that they
wanted a weak Ottoman Empire that they
could exploit if the modernizing an
assertive Egypt were to have won the war
then the European powers could have been
shut out and lost their influence in the
region the most important aspect of
international diplomacy for the Ottomans
in the second half of the 19th century
was its relationship with Russia
so Russia considered itself the
protector of all Christians within the
Ottoman Empire and France under Napoleon
the third wish to take that mantle for
itself
the Russians demanded that their
position be respected these demands
weren't met and war the Russians invaded
the Balkan principalities of Moldavia
and Wallachia thus beginning the Crimean
War France and Britain worried about
Russia becoming too powerful chose to
intervene on the side of the Ottomans
alongside the Sardinians long story
short the Russians did well initially
the Allies invaded Crimea hence the name
a bunch of people died in the Russian -
an internal problem suit for peace in
1856
the peace didn't really change much
except he prevented the militarization
of the Black Sea which weakened Russia
it also demanded that the Ottomans give
Christians equal rights to Muslims which
to be fair to them they were doing
anyway the Ottoman decline had been
halted but only temporarily and only
because it suited some of the great
powers the next couple of decades were
fairly quiet for the Ottomans barring a
failed rebellion in Crete in the
unification of Wallachia and Moldavia in
1862 and
what would later be called Romania this
period also importantly saw the Ottoman
Empire used more foreign credit
furthermore the Egyptians began to drift
further away from the Ottoman orbit when
the Suez Canal was opened in 1869 giving
France and Britain a financial stake
there so the 1870s was a decade of
immense difficulty for the Ottomans in
1871 a crop failure led to a revolt in
Bosnia and Herzegovina which in turn led
to these provinces not paying their
taxes which put strain on the Ottoman
finances this combined with the
inefficiencies of the Ottoman
bureaucracy the lavish lifestyle of its
sultan abdul aziz and the immense cost
of the armed forces led the ottomans to
default in 1876 to make matters worse
hurts governor went into full revolt in
1875 in bulgaria followed suit the
following year things got even worse
when sultan abdul aziz was overthrown in
a coup and replaced by his nephew Murad
v
Murad had a long and successful reign by
which I meant he was in charge for 93
days before he himself was overthrown in
favour of his brother abdul hameed ii
abdul hameed attempted to bring in some
reforms the most notable being the
ottoman Constitution of 1876 this
allowed for elections and took some
power from the Sultan but ultimately it
would be repealed only two years later
abdul hameed
early reign got off to a rocky start
when both Serbia Montenegro declared war
the Ottomans were able to crush the
uprising in Bulgaria and they did so
brutally which brought international
condemnation especially from Russia the
great powers sought to find a solution
to the Balkan crisis but the ottomans
rejected the demands and so war Romania
still an ottoman vassal allowed Russia
to cross through its territory and soon
after declared its independence the
Russian troops reached Bulgarian
alongside the fences from Bulgarian
Serbs and Montenegrins the ottomans
didn't fare too well after pressure from
the other great powers the Russians sued
for peace and the Ottomans were forced
to sign the Treaty of San Stefano in
1877 which turned the Balkans from this
to this the Bulgarian state was supposed
to be a Russian puppet which would give
Russia access to the Mediterranean ports
which Britain did not like because
Britain like Russia trapped in the Black
Sea as a response the Congress of Berlin
was called the next year and the
territories were rearranged by the great
powers in the end this was agreed on
Romania Serbia and Montenegro became
fully independent Bosnia and Herzegovina
were occupied by Austria Hungary and
Bulgaria was to be a semi independent
principality onto the rule of Prince
Alexander the first another treaty saw
Britain gained Cyprus France gained
Tunisia and Greece gained this territory
to make things worse for the Ottomans
the Great Powers created the Ottoman
public debt administration to make sure
that the Empire never defaulted on its
debts the opda took over a significant
chunk of the Ottoman economy and created
monopolies and products like tobacco and
cotton in order to guarantee that
foreign investors would get their money
for an influence increase when the
British occupied Egypt in 1882 mostly to
secure the Suez Canal from revolt in
Egypt but also because they could the
Ottoman Empire was not without power
though it was importantly one of the few
independent Muslim states in the world
and the Sultan was the Calif the latest
in the line of succession to the Prophet
Muhammad and the spiritual head of Islam
the Ottomans wanted to keep this status
and so Abdul Hameed sought to modernize
the state to protect it
this included wide-ranging educational
reform including universal education but
also saw the creation of an intrusive
state surveillance apparatus state
surveillance was needed to root out
opposition to the Sultan which have been
growing through many secret societies
which operated both inside and outside
of the Empire the most notable of these
being the committee of Union and
progress and the Young Turks the Young
Turk revolution broke out in 1908 in
Macedonia with the intent of preventing
the carving up of the Empire's Balkan
provinces by the great powers and
reissuing the Constitution of 1876
capitalizing on the internal chaos
Bulgaria declared independence Greece
and excrete and austria-hungary formally
annex Bosnia and Herzegovina but it was
basically there's already the Revolution
was successful sort of and the Sultan
conceded to the Young Turks demands
before too much damage was done things
wouldn't settle down though since the
counter coup was launched the next year
by the more religiously conservative
officers in the army this coup failed
abdul hameed ii was blamed and later
deposed in favour of his brother Mehmet
v the new Sultan along with important
reformers like Ismail Enver sought to
unify and strengthen the Empire
these reforms went quite well at first
but again trouble came a-knockin this
time in the shape of a boot a boot
called Italy who invaded the Ottoman
province of Tripolitania now known as
Libya in 1911 the italians won handily
taking the north african territories in
these islands seeing how weak the
ottomans were many Balkan nations
capitalized and invaded beginning the
first balkan war the ottomans lost
albania became independent and the
balkans went from this to this bulgaria
was unhappy with these gains and so
about four seconds after this the second
Balkan war began the ottomans sided with
Serbia Greece and Romania Bulgaria lost
and the Balkans were carved up again so
the next year 1914 was a big year for
the Ottoman since World War
one long story short the war was lost
and after the Ottoman surrender the
British and French under the sykes-picot
agreement carved up the empire the Turks
were not happy about having their
country occupied and so fought back
against the Allied powers beginning the
Turkish war of independence they were
led by a man could mustafa kemal in the
1920 election saw his party victorious
the British unhappy with this dissolved
the Parliament and so Kemal founded a
new seat of power the Grand National
Assembly in Ankara war broke out soon
afterwards and within three years
against all odds the Turkish were
victorious driving out the occupying
powers and asserting their independence
in these borders the last Sultan Mehmet
the sick was deposed and the position of
Sultan abolished in 1922 thus formally
ending the 600 year old Ottoman Empire
the next year on October 29th 1923 the
Republic of Turkey was declared with
Kemal as its first president in 1934 he
would be granted the title Ataturk the
father of the Turks I hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
there are some book recommendations in
the description below if you'd like to
know more
you